like it or not Donald Trump is on his
way to scoring the magic number of
Delegates needed to clinch the
Republican nomination for president but
what happens if he and everyone else
falls short well then the nominee would
be decided at the Republican convention
in July where Trump could be stopped
because remember nearly 2,500 delegates
from all 50 states are the ones who
actually picked the nominee based on how
the primaries went and they do that at
party conventions you know those big to
dues where the vote is usually
ceremonial because there's almost always
a nominee by convention time but let's
just say this July there isn't a clear
winner and Trump doesn't clinch the win
in the first round of prevention voting
if this happens we have a brokered
convention and things get interesting
the vote goes to a second round but this
time most delegates are allowed to vote
for whoever they want as the voting
rounds continue more and more delegates
are allowed to change their vote and
this goes on until we have a winner
isn't democracy weird so yes Donald
Trump could conceivably be stuck at the
convention if the anti-trump movement is
strong but don't get your hopes up for
say an eleventh-hour John Kasich
nomination last election the RNC made a
rule that the nominee must have also won
the majority of Delegates in eight
states Kasich has only done that in one
state Trump you've done it in 12 the RNC
can scrap that rule or any rule really
before the convention but then it might
appear they were purposefully sabotaging
the guy who's been the consistent
frontrunner so a brokered convention
could stop Trump but is that good for
democracy